YEAR FERENZ ISN'T GIVING UP HIS
FIGHT FOR JUSTICE OR HIS FAITH
IN PEACE.
>> BENJAMIN FERENZ, WELCOME TO
THE PROGRAM.
>> THANK YOU.
>> IT'S REALLY EXTRAORDINARY TO
BE ABLE TO TALK TO YOU ABOUT
YOUR VAST EXPERIENCE SO RELEVANT
NOW, AS ALWAYS.
I JUST WONDER, BECAUSE I'VE
HEARD THAT YOU CAN DO IT, RECITE
FROM MEMORY YOUR OPENING
STATEMENT FROM YOUR PROSECUTING
CASE FROM 1947 AT NUREMBERG.
>> WELL, THAT'S QUITE A
CHALLENGE, BUT IF I RECALL, MAY
IT PLEASE YOUR HONOR, IT IS WITH
SORROW AND WITH HOPE THAT WE
HERE DISCLOSE THE DELIBERATE
MURDER OF OVER A MILLION
INNOCENT AND DEFENSELESS PEOPLE.
VENGEANCE IS NOT OUR GOAL, NOR
DO WE SEEK MERELY A JUST
RETRIBUTION.
WE ASK THIS COURT TO AFFIRM BY
INTERNATIONAL PENAL ACTION,
MAN'S RIGHT TO LIVE IN PEACE AND
DIGNITY REGARDLESS OF HIS RACE
OR CREED.
THE CASE WE PRESENT IS A PLEA OF
HUMANITY THROUGH LAW.
>> THAT IS EXTRAORDINARY TO HEAR
THAT NOW, AND I ASKED YOU
BECAUSE YOU'VE HAD A REMARKABLE,
REMARKABLE CAREER EVEN BEFORE
YOU WERE PROSECUTOR.
YOU WERE IN WORLD WAR II.
YOU LANDED IN NORMANDY.
IT WAS AROUND THE BATTLE OF THE
BULGE, BUT AFTERWARDS YOU WERE
ASSIGNED TO GO TO THE DEATH
CAMPS TO BUCHENWALD TO TRY TO
COLLECT THE EVIDENCE.
WHAT MUST THAT HAVE BEEN LIKE?
WHAT DID YOU SEE WHEN YOU WENT
THERE?
>> IT WAS HORROR.
IT WAS INCREDIBLE.
MY ASSIGNMENT WAS TO GET THE
EVIDENCE OF THE CRIMES.
THERE WAS NO DIFFICULTY.
THE EVIDENCE WAS LYING DEAD IN
EVERY CAMP I WENT INTO.
THEIR EYE, SOME OF THEM WERE
STILL PLEADING FOR HELP.
SOME WERE DIGGING IN THE GARBAGE
HOPING TO FIND A PIECE OF BREAD.
THAT WAS THE SCENE THAT I SAW,
AND IT WAS SIMILAR IN EVERY CAMP
TO WHICH I WENT.
I PROCEEDED THEN, THOF COURSE,
SEIZE WHATEVER DOCUMENTATION WAS
STILL THERE.
FORTUNATELY FOR ME AND
UNFORTUNATELY FOR THEM, THE
SPECIAL EXTERMINATION SQUADS
RECORDED EACH TOWN THEY WERE IN,
WHO WAS THE COMMANDING OFFICER
AND HOW MANY JEWS AND OTHERS
THAT THEY SLAUGHTERED, AND I
CAPTURED THOSE DOCUMENTS.
WITH THAT, IT WAS VERY EASY FOR
ME TO PROCEED TO TRIAL.
I HAD NOT BEEN ORIGINALLY
ASSIGNED AS A TRIAL LAWYER.
I'D COME OUT OF THE HARVARD LAW
SCHOOL WITH HONORS SPECIALIZING,
AND I WAS A RESEARCHER FOR
INTERNATIONAL CRIMINAL LAW, AND
I WAS EAGER TO USE THE MATERIAL
I HAD SO THEY ASSIGNED ME THE
JOB OF CHIEF PROSECUTOR.
I PRESENTED MY CASE IN TWO DAYS.
I RESTED MY CASE AND CONVICTED
ALL OF THE 24 SELECTED
HIGH-RANKING NAZI OFFICIALS.
13 OF THEM WERE SENTENCED TO
DEATH.
IT WAS -- A HISTORIC TRIAL AND
THE CONVICTIONS AND THE
PROSECUTION MADE HISTORY.
>> MR. FERENZ, WHEN YOU SEE
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN UKRAINE AT
THE MOMENT, YOU KNOW, WE ALSO
HAVE FOUND OURSELVES SCENES OF
BODIES SUMMARILY EXECUTED, JUST
THE WORST HORRORS AS THE RUSSIAN
FORCES RETREAT FROM AROUND KYIV.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ALL THESE
YEARS LATER GIVEN WHAT YOU HOPED
WOULD BE THE CASE HOLDING THAT
CRIME ACCOUNTABLE BACK IN THE
HOLOCAUST?
>> I AM HEART BROKEN.
I HAVE SPENT THE REST OF MY LIFE
AFTER THE HOLOCAUST TRYING TO
CREATE A WORLD OF PEACE AND
HARMONY FOR EVERYONE REGARDLESS
OF THEIR RACE OR CREED, AND
WE'VE BEEN MAKING SOME PROGRESS
IN THAT DIRECTION BY CREATING
NEW INTERNATIONAL CRIMINAL
COURTS, BY TEACHING HUMANITARIAN
LAW IN UNIVERSITIES, BUT TO SEE
IT HAPPENING AGAIN, VERY
SIMILAR, KIDS BEING SHOT, HOMES
BEING BLOWN UP.
IT PAINS ME TO SEE THAT WE HAVE
LEARNED SO LITTLE FROM THE
HOLOCAUST AND FROM THE TRIALS,
AND I HOPE THAT WE WILL COME TO
OUR SENSES SOON.
I AM URGING A CEASE-FIRE
IMMEDIATELY TO ALL THE TROOPS
ENGAGED IN THESE COMBATS AND USE
THAT CEASE-FIRE TIME TO PROMISE
THEM A CONFERENCE OF ALL OF THE
LEADING PARTICIPANTS IN THE NEXT
COUPLE OF WEEKS TO FIND A
PEACEABLE SOLUTION AS WAS
ANTICIPATED WHEN THE UNITED
NATIONS CHARTER WAS DRAWN UP AND
THE MOST IMPORTANT QUOTE THAT I
HAVE FOR YOU IS A QUOTE OF MY
COMMANDING GENERAL DURING THE
WAR, COMMANDER OF ALL THE ALLIED
FORCES, GENERAL DWIGHT D.
EISENHOWER, LATER PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES, AS PRESIDENT
HE WAS LEAVING IN A VERY REAL
SENSE, WE CAN NO LONGER RELY ON
FORCE.
IF CIVILIZATION IS TO SURVIVE,
IT MUST TURN TO THE RULE OF LAW.
THOSE HAVE BEEN MY GUIDING
LIGHTS.
REPUBLICAN PRESIDENT DWIGHT D.
EISENHOWER, THE WISDOM THAT HE
PASSED ON TO THE REST OF THE
WORLD AND WHICH, UNFORTUNATELY,
IS BEING DISREGARDED TODAY.
>> DISREGARDED TERRIBLY BY
RUSSIA WHICH WAS IN PART AN ALLY
DURING WORLD WAR II AND ACTUALLY
HELPED LIBERATE SOME OF THOSE
CAMPS.
IT IS EXTRAORDINARY TO SEE WHAT
THEY ARE PERPETRATING TODAY IN
UKRAINE.
SO, MR. FERENZ, DO YOU THINK
SOMEONE LIKE VLADIMIR PUTIN AND
HIS COMMANDING GENERALS CAN BE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE ALREADY?
OUR WORLD LEADERS ARE ACCUSING
HIM OF WAR CRIMES.
WE JOURNALISTS AND OTHERS HAVE
DISCOVERED THE EVIDENCE, AND
TODAY WE HAVE THE VIDEO ALL
THOSE YEARS AGO, YOU HAD THE
DOCUMENTS.
DO YOU BELIEVE THAT HE CAN BE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE?
>> CERTAINLY HE CAN BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
YOU CANNOT JUSTIFY BY ANY
ARGUMENT THE MURDER OF YOUNG
CHILDREN TAKING THEM OUT OF
HOSPITALS, KILLING THEIR PARENTS
THAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENING
REPEATEDLY AND THE CRIMES WERE
PUNISHABLE NOT ONLY AT NUREMBERG
AND IN LATER JURISDICTIONS.
YOU HAVE THE AGGRESSION, THE
INVASION OF UKRAINE CAN CLASSIFY
AS A CLEAR CASE OF AGGRESSION
AND MURDER HAS ALWAYS BEEN A
CRIME AGAINST HUMANITY, SO
THERE'S NO DIFFICULTY IN
CLASSIFYING THE NATURE OF THE
EXISTENCE OF THE CRIMES UNDER
WHICH WHOEVER IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
IT CAN BE HELD TO ACCOUNT AND
MR. PUTIN, IF HE BE THE MAN WHO
IS BEHIND ALL THIS WOULD
CERTAINLY HAVE A TOUGH TIME
WALKING OUT OF THE COURTROOM.
>> HOW WOULD YOU ENVISION THAT
INTO WHAT KIND OF COURTROOM
BECAUSE YOU WERE INSTRUMENTAL IN
HELPING TO SET UP THE
INTERNATIONAL CRIMINAL COURT,
BUT NEITHER RUSSIA NOR UKRAINE
AND NOR THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA ARE SIGNATORIES AND
PARTICIPANTS.
HOW DO YOU ENVISION IN WHAT
FORUM PROSECUTING THE CRIMES OF
THIS WAR?
>> WE HAVE SET THE MODEL BY THE
EXISTING COURTS.
UNFORTUNATELY, NOT EVERY NATION
IS WILLING TO ACCEPT AN
OBLIGATION NOT TO MURDER THE
PEOPLE THEY THINK ARE THEIR
ENEMIES.
SO WE HAVE ENOUGH MODELS AND
ENOUGH DIFFERENT COURTS.
WE HAVE CRIMES COMMITTED IN
YUGOSLAVIA AND OTHER PLACES.
THERE IS NO SHORTAGE OF MODELS
AND WHERE TO PUT THEM.
THE DIFFICULTY IS TO GET THEM TO
ACCEPT THE JURS DISDICTION OF T
COURT.
THE CRIMINALS WILL NEVER WANT TO
HAVE A COURT, BUT IT IS UP TO
THE PUBLIC TO EITHER PUT THEM IN
JAIL OR PUT THEM ON TRIAL OR
THROW THEM OUT OF OFFICE.
THEY CANNOT CONTINUE THIS WAY TO
HAVE PEOPLE OF IMPORTANCE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION OFFICE TELLING
THEIR TROOPS TO GO OUT AND KILL
PEOPLE THEY DON'T EVEN KNOW FOR
CRIMES THEY CAN'T EVEN DESCRIBE
AND THEY KILL THEM BY THE
HUNDREDS AND THE THOUSANDS.
THAT'S THE WORLD IN WHICH WE
LIVE, AND IT'S A WORLD WHICH I
AM STILL TRYING TO C